[Musique]
défiler militaires devant le palais
présidentiel et chant autochtone pour
symboliser sa diversité
nationale de la République de Chine
c'est le nom officiel de l'île
des célébrations qui ont lieu cette fois
sous un ciel gris et menaçant quelques
jours seulement après que Pékin est
encore une fois répété son intention de
réunifier Taïwan avec le continent dans
le contexte actuel de vivre tension avec
la Chine les célébrations ont une forte
saveur politique la présidente de Taïwan
assure qu'il n'y a aucun compromis
possible quant à la sécurité nationale
et à la défense de la démocratie
dans son discours elle affirme que la
destruction de la liberté et de la
démocratie de Taïwan serait un grave
échec pour les démocraties du monde
un discours axé sur la résistance et la
résilience qui attise le sentiment de
fierté
une forte majorité de taïwanais
considère que l'île est un État
souverain l'appartenance identitaire à
Taïwan est plus forte chez les jeunes
générations
à se rassemblement du principal parti
d'opposition le KMT dans le cadre d'une
campagne électorale à la mairie les
partisans disent partager les valeurs de
démocratie et de liberté mais la foule
est plus âgées et le sentiment
d'appartenance à Taïwan moins fort
nous avons la même culture et les mêmes
ancêtres que les chinois a dit celui-ci
la réunification et le but ultime
indépendance réunification la vaste
majorité des taïwanais estiment que
c'est à eux de décider
on ne sait pas de quoi est fait l'avenir
dit-il mais c'est à nous de le décider
le président chinois si j'ai une ping
dirait le contraire il devrait obtenir
un troisième mandat historique la
semaine prochaine la réunification est
un de ces grands objectifs il suffit
Leblanc Radio-Canada Taipei